[Música]
[Aplausos]
op mar convicção ritmo e durante muitos
anos eu intuía uma viagem pra deveria
fazer essa viagem que está próximo a
dois grupos de pessoas com realidades
bem distintas a minha que está próximo a
pessoas em situação de mendicância em
áreas de vulnerabilidade drogas
marginalização miséria de todo tipo
eu também queria estar próximo a pessoas
do interior pessoas que vivem com muita
dificuldade e por isso talvez com muita
simplicidade pessoas que cuidam da terra
sobrevivem do trabalho braçal
eu consegui realizar essa viagem quando
eu sair para a estrada não tinha um
motivo muito claro porque eu estava indo
de onde vinha essa minha necessidade era
simplesmente uma intuição
eu também não sabia exatamente o que
fazer quando chegasse lá nessas áreas
então eu já tinha participado de grupos
nem fazer ações solidárias nas ruas nem
ajuda à população de rua e o grupo é
ótimo é o grupo ele mantém uma
constância uma consistência esse tipo de
ação na grupo de vide méritos
o grupo trabalha a nossa humildade para
acatar uma decisão que você não jogava
melhor mas o grupo filme tem uma
coisinha que ele sempre me incomodou o
grupo ele abriu e dá um espaçamento
entre as pessoas que estão indo ajudar
as pessoas que estão sendo assistidas né
acho que inconscientemente eu já me
percebi assim ó estamos chegando nosso
nós com a nossa camisa que do nosso
grupo e vamos ajudar essas pessoas
necessitadas e eles pensavam olha só que
legal o pessoal tá chegando vem nos
ajudar a troca geralmente é muito boa
mas eu precisava sentir aquela realidade
de uma maneira mais plena de uma maneira
mais profunda
então é 100 grupo eu fui sozinho e
comecei a ir para essas áreas né de
vulnerabilidade de drogas e eu acabei
encontrando muitas das respostas das
perguntas que eu não estava fazendo
eu chegava necessidades e perguntava em
padaria em banca de jornal onde tinha
grande concelho
a ação de mendigos e pra lá eu ia lá eu
fui à cracolândia em são paulo passei um
tempo lá para servir o revellion é com
os mendigos de barreiras na bahia e em
cidades grandes e as capitais e
apresenta urbanos e praças com grande
presença de mendigos
eu chegava lá com minha mochila pequena
com alguns sanduíches banana biscoito e
eu começava sentava próximo eu começava
a comer e oferecia para as pessoas que
estavam mais próximas a mim ea gente
começar a trocar idéia e eu passei a
ouvir bastante né meu intuito é saber da
sua vida do seu passado o que levou ele
essa condição de rua será marginal será
viciado mas constantemente muitos me
contavam sobre suas vidas seus passados
e o procurava ouvir atentamente e a
falar com os olhos é falar de amor de um
julgamento nem amá los com um toque com
encostar na mão encostar no ombro com um
abraço e eu fui reconhecido eu comecei a
perceber que nessas trocas né eu não
estava fazendo uma qualidade
verticalizada como eu sentia antes eu
acho até mesmo que nem era uma caridade
porque eu também falava sobre minhas
dores minhas perdas minhas alegrias né
não fazia questão de me expor como
vulnerável porque eu também sou
vulnerável
eu falava sobre as minhas dores sushi de
dores contava sobre a minha ânsia para
ser feliz porque eu tenho muita sede de
felicidade
é nessas trocas eu comecei a conhecer as
trajetórias dessas pessoas e na rua de
tudo né
e eu comecei a perceber que eu estava
venerando essas pessoas como mestres da
sobrevivência eo passeio escutá los como
um amigo e por muitas vezes eu fui
reconhecido como amigo e pra mim ser
reconhecido como amiga muito melhor do
que ser reconhecido por qualquer obra
qualquer feito qualquer palavra que eu
posso ter dado ali e depois dessas
experiências iniciais nas ruas
eu comecei a sentir a necessidade uma
vontade eu comecei a me sentir acolhido
por eles eu comecei a me sentir mais
confortável nesse tipo de ambiente
então tive uma vontade de criar laços
mais profundos eu passei a dormir na rua
eu queria estar vivendo aquela realidade
mais próximo possível apesar de saber
que se que a igualdade ela talvez não
exista né
é aí o ano nas nossas trocas durante a
noite as madrugadas assim vira e mexe o
papo ea pra eles religiosidade ou
espiritualidade e eu me ajoelhar perante
ele pediu para que eles realizassem pra
mim com a mão na minha cabeça eu tive
uma ideia e também é em alguns dias
então eu comprava a sacos de pão e fazia
sanduíche de queijo comecei a estimular
que eles distribuírem comigo pra outros
mendigos
então começou que mendigos começar a
ajudar outros mendigos e é incrível como
estar a serviço se colocar a serviço do
próximo pode regenerar o nosso espírito
não pode dar uma resposta ao sentimento
de inutilidade que essas pessoas nessas
condições de rua e eles têm pode dar uma
resposta pra mim talvez pra gente
o nosso sentimento de impotência perante
ao sofrimento do mundo né eu quando é
quando estou a serviço eu tento estimula
muito as minhas reflexões sobre as
mesmas condutas na minha família no
trabalho no trânsito no supermercado eu
acho que estar a serviço sendo solidário
acho que nos inflama a ser cada vez uma
pessoa melhor o melhor filho melhor
marido o melhor amigo melhor colega de
trabalho o melhor desempregado
o melhor é injustiçado o melhor vizinho
o melhor agredido eu comecei a dividir
um pouco dessas experiências tantas
histórias que eu tenho vivido assim os
últimos tempos
eu comecei a dividir com alguns amigos e
pessoas mais próximas e muitos assim o
elogio de corajoso e eu comecei aqui
nunca me caiu muito bem assim
eu comecei a perceber que a coragem em
muitos casos no meu ela foi um processo
bastante longo
eu lembro quando eu tinha por volta de
uns 10 12 anos eu voltava pra casa de um
futebol que jogava estava chovendo
bastante e perto da minha casa tinha um
menino de rua assim né e mais ou menos
da minha faixa etária talvez um
pouquinho mais velho já adolescente ele
estava se cobrindo da chuva e do frio
colocando a camisa sobre o joelho
sentado no meio fio e eu estava perto de
casa no fim uma boa ação mas eu me
sensibilizei com aquela cena e tirei a
minha camisa e fui entregar para ele sem
dizer nada
ele ficou espantado com aquela atitude
né ele ficou com a mão pra pegar mas
antes de agarrar a camisa ele virou para
mim
e perguntou assim você vai ficar sem ele
então aquilo me tocou profundamente
porque aquele garoto naquela
circunstância de frio de chuva de rua
desamparado de amigos e familiares por
perto ele se preocupou comigo antes de
ele aceitar uma doação é que
provavelmente faz parte de um bom efeito
ali naquela condição e por isso eu
percebo que hoje é a coragem um processo
talvez a longo prazo não é eu demorei
décadas para finalmente começar essas
incursões que eu tenho feito a minha
trajetória mais recente né e eu percebo
na verdade eu aceito esse é quando as
pessoas me chamam de de corajoso e tudo
mais mas eu não me sinto como tal porque
eu sei que na verdade estou simplesmente
seguindo uma intuição eu estou seguindo
meu coração
quando a gente sai do nosso coração a
gente não exerce uma prática da coragem
a gente exerce um ato da necessidade a
gente simplesmente precisa fazer o que
precisa ser feito para a nossa própria
vida e faz é e aceitando esses elogios
de corajoso de pessoas constantemente
perguntado se não tenho medo de ir para
essas áreas e tudo mais
eu compreendo isso tudo porque eu passei
por situações delicadas situações de
perigo mas o medo de ir de instalar
nesses ambientes nunca foi maior do que
a minha vontade de estar lá do que a
minha vontade de amar e tem uma música
de bob dylan em uma frase de uma música
dele que eu trago bastante pra minha
vida ele fala o enganar sem enganação
utiliza quando você não tem nada você
não tem nada a perder então eu tentei me
despir totalmente de quem era e do que
eu tinha que sair de casa do e todos os
meus móveis e comecei essa trajetória
então quando eu tô nesses ambientes me
levar o meu dinheiro a minha roupa é o
meu celular os meus documentos sim pra
mim pouco importa nada disso tem valor
pra mim é claro trouxeram muito pela
minha integridade física é como viver
eu não sou um kamikaze eu tomo os meus
cuidados né e tempo percebeu o perigo
antes do período se aproximar de mim
claro que não é uma ciência exata mas eu
também não posso eu comecei a sentir a
perceber nessa caminhada que nem a
própria vida me pertence
então não posso ter medo de colocar em
risco se eu tiver colocando em risco
é num ato de amor se eu tiver que perder
lá que eu sei que eu perca amando e fora
essas experiências de rua também nas
ruas é eu tenho experiência dos
interiores em fazenda das plantações e
no sertão aqui no brasil já andei um
pouco bastante também
e ir lá nesses ambientes receber lições
de vida de solidariedade assim incríveis
eu vou contar três histórias rapidinho
de tantas que eu tenho vivido mais uma
delas eu estava lá fazendo em uma das
fazendas a gente tava batendo fazendo
cimento não é batendo o cimento estava
com a pá e um companheiro lá do sertão
estava na na enxada a elite outras
pessoas por perto e se aproximou de mim
e disse baixinho que ele queria me
ensinar uma oração secreta quer uma
oração de proteção ele falou assim não
quero te ensinar sobre a ação porque
você vem de uma cidade muito perigosa no
rio de janeiro
e eu queria te proteger mesmo de longe
através dessa oração eu achei aquilo tão
bonita assim essa entrega misturando um
pouco da espiritualidade dele trazendo
um pouco ela pra mim ele só me pediu
para não dividir essa oração com ninguém
porque senão ia perder a força não valeu
de nada então eu tenho segurado ela
ninguém sabe só eu e uma outra situação
uma outra oportunidade eu estava numa
outra fazenda me despedir de todos os
meus companheiros lá de enxada do
trabalho braçal e eu fui eu ia viajar de
carona do caminhão ea fazenda que eu
tava era no piauí é ela ficava em frente
a uma br então a travessia br estava do
outro lado da estrada fazendo sinal já
estava ali para uma meia hora em um
caminhão e um carro estava parando e aí
veio um desses amigos que eu tinha
acabado de me despedir e atravessou a
rua se aproximou de mim tirou a carteira
dele e tirou a única nota que ele tinha
na carteira
ele falou pra mim que ele queria
entregar uma nota assim de valor bem
baixo mas era uma enorme era de enorme
valor humano porque ele me disse que
queria entregar porque eu podia passar
necessidade na estrada já que viajar de
carona e ele disse que já tinha passado
muita necessidade na vida dele e que ele
tinha tinha ajudado muito ele queria
fazer o mesmo por mim naquela situação
numa outra oportunidade uma situação de
de pura beleza e de bela pureza foi
quando o presente é as filhas de um
amigo de si
é com mais bonecas que eu comprei um
supermercado as bonecas super simples
assim entreguei para elas e elas ficaram
nossa muito felizes em uma delas em
êxtase de alegria
ela virou pra mim e me agradeceu e
seguinte com a seguinte frase né
que deus lhe pague que deus lhe pague e
aquilo me tocou profundamente é como uma
criança com aquela realidade tão
distinta da criança que eu fui nem pode
me agradecer por um presente tão
simplório com essa magnitude neves e
menino deus no seu agradecimento e essa
experiência dos interiores assim das
fazendas da plantação juntas desse povo
mesmo trabalho braçal acabou não
convencendo de que com uma simplicidade
é uma via a simplicidade é uma decisão
ea simplicidade ela pode ser uma solução
para a nossa vida pessoal para nossa
vida profissional pode ser uma solução
para o mundo também para as relações de
convivência as relações interpessoais
mas para a gente viver uma vida e
simplicidade tem que abrir mão de
algumas coisas né
nosso orgulho é de relações de amizade é
eu acho que principalmente é da vaidade
não só vaidade física decretar esbelta e
receber elogios e curtidas por isso e
nem a vaidade material né
somente elas nem de ostentar bens e tudo
mais mas principalmente a vaidade
intelectual porque a vaidade intelectual
que nos traz uma ilusória sede de
prestígio social
eu acho que é preciso a gente reconhecer
a grandeza de se fazer pequeno e de
querer ser anônimo é de não viver uma
vida em busca de reconhecimento fama
sucesso cargo não viver uma vida em
função dos números mas deixar que os
números nos encontrar em eu tenho
tentado praticar isso é muito muito
difícil hoje eu creio que é mais fácil
me tornar um milionário do que eu me
fazer um humilde do que me fazer pequeno
acho que é preciso que a gente olhe fora
do ponto de vista dos resultados
palpáveis as coisas que a gente faz nas
nossas vidas
quando eu saí pra essa trajetória é
nunca pensei não sabia nem o que está
fazendo então nunca pensei em termos de
eficácia do que estava fazendo
eu tenho certeza que é por isso
tenho vivido tantos momentos infinito e
atualmente o resultado ele não é meu
critério de ação para fazer nada na
minha vida né
depois dessas experiências nas ruas e
nos interiores eu comecei a reavaliar as
mesmas condutas na minha vida e comecei
a sentir um envergonhamento profundo do
meu passado é esse eu descobri uma
enorme responsabilidade que eu tenho
perante a minha existência
esse envergonhamento ele não é questão
de dinheiro ou de bens materiais
exclusivamente mas é uma questão mais de
percepção de vida né
como que eu que por décadas desde a
infância sempre me sensibilizei com
essas condições de vidas abandonadas
pude por tanto tempo só me preocupar com
as minhas conquistas com os brasileiros
com os meus relacionamentos exercitando
o meu ego o centrismo é que combina no
orgulho na minha agressividade quando eu
sou contrariado no meu machismo e nas
minhas vaidade
ainda assim essa vergonha é muito mas
ela não me paralisa ela não me traz
culpa nem depressão
ao contrário ela me traz força ela me
traz de gana para viver uma vida cada
vez mais a serviço de quem mais precisa
eu quero viver uma vida que me tire do
centro do universo e que me coloca por
último eu comecei falando aqui pra vocês
que eu queria realizar essa viagem eu
fiz essa viagem eu quero terminar
dizendo que eu ainda estou nessa viagem
e falar aqui pra vocês me faz muito bem
porque é uma possibilidade de uma
reflexão um pouco mais coletiva
essas experiências tão íntimas tenho
vivido e principalmente que é uma forma
de repetir tudo isso aqui pra mim alto e
bom som e muitas vezes essas coisas
guardadas tanto tempo só dentro de mim e
eu repito agora é pra eu mesmo ouvi isso
tudo e todas essas histórias essas
percepções de vida essa breve trajetória
recente da minha vida ela na mensagem
não tem nada nada de novo né alguns
milênios
essa idéia de amor né foi propagada pelo
mundo e foi praticada ao longo dos
séculos por milhões de pessoas
algumas poucas dessas pessoas são bem
famosas mas a grande maioria milhões são
lindamente anônimas
conhecidas e elas viver as suas vidas
assim anonimato né eu acredito que é
possível a gente viver para si
instrumento de um amor maior do amor que
não quer nada em troca de um amor que
chora junto que sonha junto que quer ver
o outro restaurado
eu acho que a postura do amor nas nossas
condutas ela não é passiva ela não é a
política
acho que a postura do amor nas nossas
vidas ela é revolucionária e tudo que o
mundo chama de utopia e de romantismo na
verdade são mudanças profundas na
maioria das mudanças profundas elas são
demorados
elas são silenciosas e elas não estão no
noticiário diário talvez por isso a
gente tenha tanta dificuldade de
mobilização é e por isso pouco importa
quanta sabedoria existe nas palavras
quanto importa a quantidade de ações que
são realizadas o que realmente afeta
nossa vida o nosso entorno é quanto amor
se é se vive e se oferece nessa passagem
e para me despedir de vocês tem mais um
pouquinho de tempo não ia falar mas eu
vou falar
eu queria compartilhar é uma dessas
respostas mais uma dessas respostas das
perguntas que eu não estava fazendo a
descobrir que talento é dom mas que
qualidade é exercício
eu não sou uma pessoa boa pra exercita a
bondade mim sempre que eu posso eu não
sou uma pessoa solidária
o exército a solidariedade mim eu não
sou uma pessoa segura do exército o
controle das minhas emoções e assim
querendo me despedir exercitando uma
qualidade que me falta tanto que nem é
tão cara eu queria exercitar minha
humildade e porque eu acho que ato de
altruísmo solidariedade não podem servir
para que eu me convença de que eu sou
uma pessoa boa decente e honesto e tal
eu afastar qualquer exaltação de mim
qualquer exaltação íntimo de mim mesmo
por isso eu peço que os aplausos de nerd
praxe nem para quando as pessoas acabam
de falar que sejam direcionadas
direcionados
essas pessoas que vivem nessas condições
e abandonadas esquecidas por nós e por
elas mesmas pessoas que vivem esmagadas
pela nossa estrutura social
boto a mão no lixo para sobreviver do
homem com a cabeça ao relento na noite
fria e também as pessoas que sobrevivem
do trabalho braçal tanto no campo quanto
na cidade né
enquanto aqui nesse prédio e por último
eu queria pedir que esses aplausos
inclusive os meus sejam direcionados aos
meus pais eles que vivem o meu lado
todos os dias
apesar de ter morrido na minha frente
eles me ensinaram o que é o amor
eles salvaram minha vida
[Aplausos]
[Música]